i want to talk about ownership and uh
could you
explain
your book what's the explanation behind
the title
actually came from an email that i sent
to
a uh you know grew up
a manager in a company and and the email
basically said
we when i was in the seal teams and i
was a troop commander so i was in charge
of task unit bruiser and we were getting
ready to go on deployment and
occasionally the commodore which is a
couple ranks above my boss actually one
rank above my boss is a guy named the
commodore which is you know a full bird
colonel
if you're in the marine corps or the
army
and he's kind of in charge of all the
seal teams on the west coast and so he
would have occasional meetings where
he'd bring in us the troop commanders
and we're like the front line guys and
this is west coast of the u.s west coast
of the u.s
and
the story that i told in this email
was that he would go around the room
because he wants to get some direct
feedback from the troops and he'd ask
somebody you know okay what do you need
and these guys are my peers
and you know
someone would say well you know the
boots that we have are okay in the hot
weather but we're getting ready to be in
a cooler environment we need new boots
uh and we need them by this date because
that's our next training block
okay got it and you get the next person
say you know when we're out at the
desert training facility
there's no wi-fi internet so our guys
are disconnected
and you know we really need to get wi-fi
out there okay got it and the next guy
would say
we need more helicopter training support
because we don't feel like we're working
around helicopters enough and we really
need that
and eventually get to me i need you know
commodore would say jocko what do you
need and i would say we're good sir
and
i i was
stating the obvious which is if i have
problems i'm going to handle them and
i'm going to take care of them i'm not
going to complain
i i took extreme ownership of my world
and
the way that worked two-fold was when i
did need something it number one it was
something significant it was something
real and when i told the commodore hey
boss
we need this right here i i would almost
get it instantaneously because he knew
that i really truly needed it and so i
i'd written this kind of told that story
and and talked about extreme ownership
and to and owning everything in your
world because the other piece that is
you
you complain you know people complain
they place blame on other people
and finally
you know if your boss if tim's boss
isn't giving you the support you need
whose fault is that
whose fault is it
if your boss is not giving you what you
need whose fault it's at
i suppose it's my fault plenty of people
plenty of people will say well it's my
boss's fault no it's actually your fault
because you haven't educated them you
haven't influenced them you haven't you
haven't explained to them in a manner
they understand why you need this
support that you need and so that's
extreme ownership that's where the title
came from or you've made them
like like you uh
i suppose alluded to
you've made them uh immune to your
requests because you're the boy who
cries wolf exactly and if you're
constantly needy
they will determine that nothing is
important or or it's not a real urgent
important request
and that that really i mean that's
extreme ownership in a nutshell is
you're taking responsibility for
everything in your world and there's no
one else to blame
and when we do talk about bosses you
know i i tell this to people all the
time because you know i always hear
complain about people's bosses
and i tell people that
i worked for every different type of
boss you could imagine you know
superb tactical geniuses that were
incredible leaders of men and i've
worked for people that didn't know
anything and were
horrible
and i had the same relationship with all
of them which is
i built up trust with them so that they
trusted that i was going to do the right
thing and they gave me the support i
needed
and
that that's a that's i took ownership of
those relationships to make sure that
that was always the case and that's
another piece that i you know if you
have a problem with your boss it's not
your boss's fault it's your fault and
obviously it's the same thing down the
chain of command as well hey gary how
are you doing man super well brother so
i got a simple question kind of um i've
been doing business with my dad for the
last two years okay but because of a
couple of shady deals and some false
promises
we've unfortunately had to liquidate one
of our businesses recently okay so this
has caused me to [ __ ] hate business
okay because of all the shocks and the
shady things that happen in the business
world well maybe you should hate the
judgment calls that you and your dad
made not business yeah so so my second
question for you is how do you develop
the mindset to kind of
by becoming accountable for the [ __ ] ups
you guys made
you understand
so
so
just to give a bit of context the [ __ ]
up that we made i know the [ __ ] that we
made
is that a gentleman came to us from a
big company said yeah we're going to
give you a contract we're going to give
you a contract we're going to give a
contract
we saw the contract but it never got
delivered
happens
yeah right off you shouldn't have
listened
fair enough
you made a bad decision to believe
people need to be accountable
you know
like
i've had a really hard time getting
ripped off
that's a skill set
but it's okay because here's what's
amazing you're young as [ __ ]
so now my intuition says
you may not make that same kind of
mistake the next time
or
not put yourself in it i make mistakes
all the time
they just won't put me out of business
every time somebody comes to me lately a
lot of y'all i for some reason went on
this run of like
10 kids in like a month coming up to me
at airports saying they got ripped off
and without knowing a thing
different than your scenario i looked at
them it's and i said because you wanted
too much money fast
you know people get ripped off when they
try to make something happen too fast
a lot of times that might not be the
scenario here but
i think you're smart enough to realize
four sharks nine sharks sounds like one
big shark is not an indication to
everybody else
you know i just think everything's my
fault even when somebody steals from me
it makes me real happy
i mean it i understand how that's
you know it's my truth it's how i think
i didn't need to employ that person i
didn't need to let them into my office
i think when you go fully in on
accountability
the world gets really happy
when you think it's everybody else's
fault and you don't have control that's
where people get upset
cool thank you you're welcome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you